Laisse moi te chanter~~ !!! (chantent une merveilleuse chanson de la sublissimme chanteuse Angèle, qui n'est autre que Balance Ton Quoi)
Bienvenue à tous dans cette nouvelle vidéo. Le saviez-vous ?
La vidéo la plus vue de ma chaîne hors musique est une vidéo où on ouvre des objets "what the fuck" japonais tous les trois
*cris hystériques*
ATR ! ATR ! ATR ! Allez !
Oh !
*Chute*
Squeezie : Ça va ?
Carlito : Ça va gros ?
McFly : ça va, ça va.
Raph : 'Fin quand je dis gros...
Squeezie : La dernière fois vous n'aviez pas aimé
les intros où on est trop énergiques...
[Carlito] Ah ouais ? [SQUEEZIE] Mais en même temps on est trop contents de se retrouver parce que...
Carlito : Ecoutez, c'est comme des gamins, euh en fait vous savez, y a un truc...
Alors, j'peux me permettre ? Tu le garderas jamais au montage.
McFly : Il va parler d'endorphine !
[Carlito] Vous avez remarqué "l'endorphine" que ça génère ?
Par exemple, quand on est gamins, est-ce que vous avez remarqué ?
On boit tout le temps de l'eau comme des oufs (fous).
T'sais, quand... Non mais c'est vrai
Mais si, t'as fait du sport et tout, t'as couru, t'es là ! *borborygme* *soupir* (Bon allez) *claque*
Les gars j'ai fait 6 magasins différents,
pour essayer de choper des objets AMUSANTS pour nous.
Est-ce que tu es content de ce que tu as obtenu ?
Je suis hyper content mais c'est un peu différent de d'habitude !
Y'a des trucs vraiment nawak etc, mais y a aussi des trucs qui sont nawak mais très stylés
Vous vous souvenez comme le base-ball qu'on avait fait, qui était l'un des meilleurs moments de ma vie.
*Transition avec le bruit du jouet*
*Cri de guerre* Il est trop fort !
Il est incroyable !
*multiples chocs du jouet*
Il est incroyable, il est incroyable !
Y'aura pas de feux d'artifices dans cette vidéo, parce que c'était vraiment dangereux... *musique triste*
Non mais ça va aller, ça va aller. Mais on a failli mettre le feu
T'façon tu m'avais dit que t'avais fait un taf dessus et que ça allait beaucoup mieux
J'ai vu deux psy.
Maintenant je ne pète plus un plomb...
*En coupant Carlito* Est- ce que vous êtes prêts les gars ? C'est le début de cette vidéo !
*détonation et surprise de McFly*
*Applaudissements et rires* Carlito : Très bien, super.
OOOH ! *surprise*
Oh mon dieu !
Allez mon pote, allez, tu peux prendre sur toi ! *encouragements*
[McFly] Tu vas y arriver ! (répété trois fois)
C'est rien ! (2 fois)
Bien bravo !
Toutes ces heures de travail c'est pas pour rien !
C'est pas pour rien !
*soupirs*
ça fait longtemps qu'on s'était pas vus sur cette chaîne, les loulous !
Quel plaisir d'être...
*en coupant Carlito* Je suis pas sûr de moi ! Du tout !
*étonnements*
*cris puis rires*
[McFly] Mais p****n, m'a visé !
Lulu, vise sur la gueule !
*cris, rires et fracas*
[Carlito] Oh m***e l'ordi !
[Carlito] Oh p****n !
*étonnements et rires*
Il a pété l'ordi !
[McFly] Mais qu'est-ce-que... Mec !
[SQUEEZIE] Là par contre c'est pas juste.
[Carlito] C'est entièrement de ta faute.
Excuse-moi ! Le mec me vise avec un lance-roquettes !
*contestation de SQUEEZIE*
J'vais l'dégager.
En tout cas il marche encore !
[McFly] Mec c'est incroyable ! Ce jet dans la gueule !
[SQUEEZIE] Les gars, j'suis heureux. ça m'avait manqué d'vous ramener des objets...
*McFly félicite*
Y'a une p'tite tradition dans ces vidéos là...
C'est la p'tite perruque pour toi et moi,
et c'est le p'tit costume pour toi !
Oui~~ !
J'en ai marre d'être nu.
Allez, allez on y va... C'est parti !
[Carlito] On respecte les traditions !
Après y'a plein de petits jeux, et vous allez devoir être bon les gars. Je sais que vous mauvais aux jeux, là vous allez devoir DÉCHIRER !
Elles sont très, très, très, très nulles.
Alors moi, y'a même plus d'effort, c't'a dire qu'il n'y a même plus de faux poils... C'est du pur plastique,
mais toi, y'a un peu de moquette !
*ensemble* Y'a un peu de douceur !
[McFly ]Y a de la soie [SQUEEZIE] Y a un genre de soie c'est vraiment très doux, c'est agréable [McFly] Héhé voilà, ça fait bien plaisir au moins...
*petits rires*
Le bruit !
'Faut qu'tu...
*sauts et cliquetis des billes*
What is the f**k ?
*rires* [SQUEEZIE] Je sais pas !
Attends, y'a un truc écrit dessus, non ?
O.K., il faut que t'arrives à faire ça, c'est un jeu qu'est très connu, faut qu't'arrives à faire ça, j'te montre...
[Carlito] C'est un jeu qu'est très connu... ça tout le monde le connait !
*rires* [SQUEEZIE] T'es le premier à essayer de le faire au monde, vas-y faut que ça fasse des pile
[McFly] Faut que tu fasses comme ça là... Des petits sauts réguliers !
[McFly] pas mal...Pas mal... PAS MAL !
[SQUEEZIE ]Pas mal, pas mal, pas mal, pas mal !
[Carlito ]ALLEZ !
Attends moi je veux entendre 3 tacs d'affilé.
3 d'affilé, 3 d'affilé
Allez ça va
*cris*
Eh, vous voulez plaire à McFly et Carlito, vous leur achetez un slip
Vraiment ça leur fait un plaisir fou
SIX ! Six, six, six ! *cris de McFly*
[SQUEEZIE] à moi, à moi, à moi !
On fait vraiment des vidéos qui ne nécessitent aucune activité cérébrale
J'ai jamais vu ça
Mais le champion !
Mais regardez-moi !
Faites-en des GIFS ! Faites-en des GIFS !
C'est le champion
Il est meilleur que les japonais !
Mais mec c'est fou ! C'est le gars qui est fort dans tous les jeux au bahut
Oh put**n la surprise !
Gardes-le, ne l'enlèves pas ! J'ai envie de dire Bravo
Les gars j'ai déjà besoin de ventoline
Les amis on va faire un tournoi de ce jeu. C'est le "slipos on the head" ok ?
Chacun à notre tour on va s'affronter en 1v1
Le gagnant du tournoi  a un cadeau de ma part, c'est pas une blague !
Le gagnant du tournoi  a un vrai cadeau cool, vraiment un cadeau cool
Alors, chacun met le slip bien sur la tête, on enfile bien, tel un bonnet de bain
Ce sont des influenceurs
Et l'arbitre dira "3 2 1 Go" et à son "Go", le but
C'est d'être le dernier avec un slip sur la tête
Oui d'enlever le slip de l'autre finalement
[SQUEEZIE] C'est... c'est parti là ? [Carlito] Oui oui
*cris*
J'peux avoir le cadeau j'peux avoir le cadeau ?!
[Carlito] Mais nan mais t'es con ! [SQUEEZIE] Attends ! [Carlito] Y a un tournoi mec !
Cet homme ne connaît pas le principe des tournois !
[SQUEEZIE] Alors, si tu bats Raph, t'as gagné le tournois gros
Put**n mais c'est horrible ça !
OK, les gars vous êtes prêts ?
Deuxième manche du tournois : 3, 2, 1, ça tourne !
C'est qui le patron ? Boum ! Bouuum !
Bravo ! Ton cadeau, c'est un gatchapon mec. Les gens vont être émus que je t'offre un gashapon !
[McFly] Ooooh styléé !
[SQUEEZIE] Un vrai gashapon de Tokyo avec dedans, un p'tit porte-clefs !
Ooooh, j'suis content j'ai vu que t'ouvrais ça sur Instagram !
[SQUEEZIE] Très déçu, il est déçu, il est déçu [Carlito] Naan !
C'est supeeer !
Ok !
Tiens ton cadeau même pour toi qui est perdant.
Oh j'adore quand ça fait ça j'ai un cadeau très stylé et lui, moyen, c'est le meilleur moment j'ai un Luffy trop cool !
J'ai un Luffyyy !
Mais nan mais Vida c'est pas grave mec
C'est quoi c'est un Shiba qui la tête coincée dans un parpaing ? Yes
Attends tu viens de le heu [McFly] Il est là, il est là j'ai mis dans ma poche là
Les gars, nouvel objet
Ha, ho ouii
Le "tire sur mon doigt" !
Le but du jeu est simple les amis
à tour de rôle nous avons
une petite roulette et nous voyons combien de fois il faut tirer sur son doigt.
Celui qui fait exploser le cucul du singe perd.
Ah, la case où y a pas de chiffre.
Zéro.
Quel bonheur.
C'est pas l'bonheur de s'retrouver les gars ?
Zéro.
Bon bah c'est bien cette vidéo elle est bien rythmée.
*rire de McFly*
Trois !
Allez, tu tires trois fois sur le doigt.
Une fois.
Deux fois.
Le cul gonfle hein
Ha ouais c'est vrai !
C'est pas vrai ?!
J'te jure
Ah oui le cul gonfle !
Quel bonheur ce tournage !
C'est la meilleure chose
Ha ! Attendez
C'était le pire jeu de leur vie
Et il a suffit de dire "le cul gonfle" pour que ça *rires*
*musique*
*bruit de flatulences*
*rires*
Tout ça pour ça !
Jamais autant de gens en même temps en France n'ont soufflé du nez ! Jamais !
Réaction d'un viewer :
*rires*
Tu sais ce qu'il y a de mieux que "slipos on the head" mec ?!
Non y a mieux ?
"Color on the head" !
ça s'joue jusqu'a quatre !
[McFly] Oh là là là là là !
Là on va vraiment avoir l'air d'abrutis.
Vous êtes prêts les gars ?
*rires*
Attendez les gars les gars !
On est d'accord qu'mon visage il est normal à moi ?
*rires*
[McFly] *rires* ça n'a pas changé ton visage !
ça n'impacte pas ton visage.
Ok les gars vous êtes prêts ?
3, 2, 1, go !
*musique épique*
[Carlito] Oh non !
[McFly] Allez là !
*cris de liesse et de soulagement*
[Carlito] Quel winner lui !
Ne faites pas ça chez vous
[Carlito] Oh regardez j'fais partie d'un gang !
Regarde ma gueule !
David c'est toi qui va activer ça.
J'ai aucune idée de ce que ça fait
Je sais pas pourquoi je l'ai acheté
Mais j'me suis dit ça va être drôle deee découvrir ça avec eux.
A-allez !
[SQUEEZIE] T'es sûr qu'fallait mettre du feu ?
[McFly] Pas sûr...
*musique thème de "joyeux anniversaire"*
[McFly] Ooooh !
Le feu a déclenché une musique !
WOUAAAH
[Carlito] C'est la meilleure chose !
*cris*
[Carlito] J'veux ça pour nos enfants !
Mais oui c'est génial !
Si y a un peu des business-man, business-woman,
Importez ça hein !
Les gamins vont kiffer !
[McFly] On souffle tous les trois ensemble ?
3, 2, 1...
[Carlito] Ah nan nan mais en compte à rebours ou en décompte fin eeen...
[McFly] Nan on fait 3, 2, 1 et zéro imaginaire on souffle [SQUEEZIE] Voilà !
3, 2, 1...
[McFly] Attend-tend-tend-tend !
Le zéro, on le dit ou pas ?
[SQUEEZIE] Nan ! 3, 2, 1...
[McFly] Espèce de gâcheur !
[Carlito] T'es chiant !
[McFly] C'est la meilleure chose
[SQUEEZIE] J''commence, j'commence ?
[Carlito] Ouaais, vas-yy, Lucas allez Lucas, Lucas
*bruit de choc*
*rires*
*cris de Lucas*
[SQUEEZIE] Zéro.
[Carlito] Il l'a éteint !
[McFly] Taper fort sur un objet en plastique !
Il l'a brisé !
Immédiatement !
Au premier coup c'est brisé !
[SQUEEZIE] Vous savez ce qu'on va faire surtout ?
On va ESSAYER L'DEUXIEEEME
*cris*
[SQUEEZIE] Ici, c'est la pichenette.
[McFly] Oh la pichenette c'est génial
[SQUEEZIE] Regardez c'est VRAIMENT
on TRICHE pas
C'est la pichenette
[Carlito] J'suis trop content d'tes jeux.
[SQUEEZIE] C'est la pichenette
[Carlito] Oui mais ne l'redis...
[SQUEEZIE] Ouais ouais donc là, c'est la PICHENETTE
[McFly] OK, j'savais pas
[SQUEEZIE] L'un de vous deux commence. Qui commence ?
[Carlito] Erreur E-1, erreur 1
[McFly] J'ai raté, j'ai raté
*cri de douleur de McFly*
[McFly] Laissez-moi refaire !
Woohoho
OK
[SQUEEZIE] 597 pas mal, pas mal, pas mal
[McFly] Allez vas-y
Oh l'batârd
*cris de Lucas*
[McFly] Oh la pichenette de l'oreille
qui fait si mal
Tu l'a pris en index
et moi j'lai pris en majeur
[Carlito] Pour quel doigt Lucas va-t-il opter ?
[Carlito] Lucas wo-ho-ho mec mais...
[SQUEEZIE] Pardon les gars c'était une pichenette instincitve...
[Carlito] Wowowo
[SQUEEZIE] C'EST BON LACHE-MOI
[Carlito] Calme-toi mec
[SQUEEZIE] J'la refais c'est bon !
[McFly] Oh l'batârd j'suis vraiment l'plus mauvais
[SQUEEZIE] YEEEES !
*cris de joie de Carlito et Squeezie*
[SQUEEZIE] Les gars, ça !
[McFly] Woooh
[SQUEEZIE] Là, on est sur un vrai jeu !
On va jouer par terre et on va dessiner un cercle
Et comme les sumos le premier qui fait sortir
l'autre du cercle
gagne.
[McFly] Belle maîtrise du...Du rond à main levée quand même hein
[SQUEEZIE] Match en trois points
Le premier
qui tombe
ou qui sort du cercle
a perdu.
[Carlito] Ou qui abandonne
si on respecte les traditions des tournois d'arts martiaux des mangas
[SQUEEZIE] Vous êtes prêts ?
3, 2, 1, GO !
*musique*
[McFly] Ouais !
1 - 0, 1 -0 !
[Carlito] Ah mais t'as fait une technique "dos" là
[McFly] Technique du dos, technique du cul ça s'appelle !
[Carlito] Vas-y
[SQUEEZIE] GO !
*musique*
[Carlito] Mais non regardez !
*cris*
[Carlito] Le mec est plus fort !
[McFly] Bah nan nan le mec est plus tactique !
[Carlito] Mais pas du tout !
[McFly] Le mec il s'est mieux entraîné !
[Carlito] Mais c'est incoyable y'en a un juste qui est plus lourd que l'autre !
[SQUEEZIE] Alleeez !
Balle de match pour David C'EST PARTI !
*musique*
*cris*
[Carlito] C'est génial !
[SQUEEZIE] GO !
*musique*
*cris*
[SQUEEZIE] Balle de match !
Messieurs-dames respirez un grand coup !
ça joue !
*cris*
[Carlito] C'est ça qu'on veut mesdames et messieurs !
C'est génial !
Oooh j'suis heureux !
[McFly] Venez on loue le stade de France on le FAIT !
*rires*
[SQUEEZIE] Les mecs est-ce que vous avez pas rêvé d'avoir ça quand vous étiez petits ?
[McFly] Bah du coup on sait pas trop c'que...
[Carlito] Ah j'adore, j'suis fan
[McFly] Oooooh
[Carlito] J'suis imbattable alors là, Taupy Keur (?) là, j'suis imbattable les gars
[McFly] Oh Taupy Keur de ouf
[SQUEEZIE] C'est le célèbre jeu où les taupes sortent à tour de rôle et vous devez les taper avec le marteau
Pour savoir qui gagne c'est très simple
pour commencer le jeu faut mettre ça tout à gauche
j'vous montre
ça joue
Quand ça ça arrive à droite
le jeu s'arrête.
Plus vous tapez sur des taupes, moins vite il va vers la droite.
[McFly]Là c'est bien on va pouvoir le mettre bien
[SQUEEZIE] Chacun votre tour, vous allez taper sur les taupes.
[McFly] Est-ce qu'on peut dire : on va "tauper" du coup ?
[SQUEEZIE] Je vais vous chronométrer
Le gagnant du tournoi , celui qui fait le plus petit temps
Le plus long temps pardon
Remporte un vrai objet trop cool.
Vraiment. Vraiment !
[Carlito] Tu joues toi aussi tu joues ?
[SQQUEEZIE] Je joue aussi.
Qui commence ?
[McFly] Attends faut qu'j'm'échauffe les poignets
[SQUEEZIE] T'es prêt ?
[McFly] On met pas un chronomètre pour savoir qui a gagné ?
[SQUEEZIE] *rire* Ah oui !
[McFly] Sinon comment savoir ?
[SQUEEZIE] Je mets j'appuie sur démarrer
Top !
[SQUEEZIE] 15 secondes 04, qu'est-ce qu'il y a David ?
[McFly] J'aurai pas le cadeau...
*rires*
[SQUEEZIE] T'es prêt Raph ?
[Carlito] Nan nan
Nan mais j'suis pas prêt gros
Mec heuu
Y a un temps de concentration y a un truc
[McFly] 1, 2, 3
[SQUEEZIE] 16:93 !!!
Daviid
[Carlito] Alors
[SQUEEZIE] Et j'ai pas dit mais le perdant y a un cadeau pour lui aussi
Pour le grand perdant
[McFly] Ah cool !
3, 2, 1
[McFly] Mais y'en a plus un seul !
Y en a plus !
Attends...
[McFly] Hop !
[SQUEEZIE] YEES ! C'est toi le dernier !
16:60 messieurs-daaaaames
[SQUEEZIE] Ok les gars
Bon bah je voulais le faire gagner mais
[McFly] C'était la dernière fois
...la dernière fois qu"on joue à ce jeu...
[SQUEEZIE] L'HEEUURE des cadeaux
Premier cadeau pour le perdant
[Carlito] Avec moi...
[McFly] Je sens que ça va être sympa
[SQUEEZIE] Là ça va être un vrai cadeau stylé David...
[McFly] Ah ouais ?
[SQUEEZIE] Ferme les yeux, j'te l'amène, et quand t'ouvres mec tu vas être trop content.
[McFly] Ah j'ferme les yeux et tout vraiment ?
[McFly] C'est quoi ce bruit là ?
[SQUEEZIE] C'est le cadeau mec. C'est trop stylé.
Fallait qu'je gazifie l'truc.
[McFly] Putain chan*
tilly.
[SQUEEZIE] C'est un gag heuu
très ANCIEN
*rire de McFly*
qui a plutôt mal vieilli d'ailleurs
*rires*
et qui est pas SI rigolo...
[Carlito] C'est pas l'meilleur moment d'la vidéo.
[McFly] Eh regarde, t'es un pokémon, j't'attrape dans ma Pokéball
[SQUEEZIE] Ok les gars
Les gars
c'est un jeu
[McFly] Oh noon je vois ça
J'ai vu quelques logos j'aime pas ça.
[SQUEEZIE] On va tous mettre not' petit doigt là-d'dans
[McFly] Oh naaan
[Carlito] Oh nan l'électricité ? Ooh
[McFly] Oh naan
Et c'est quoi c'est juste tu t'fais électrocuter?
[SQUEEZIE] Ouais c'est gratuit
*rires*
[SQUEEZIE] Nan c'est aléatoire ! C'est aléatoire c'est aléatoire
[McFly] Je déteste ça.
[SQUEEZIE] Chacun, chacun un doigt d'dans, allez. Allez allez allez !
[McFly] J'aime pas du tout faire ça put**n
[SQUEEZIE] Chacun un doigt d'dans
[McFly] Attends-tends-tends-tends-tends, j'te JURE
[Carlito] Bon allez...T'sais quoi ? Mentalement faut y aller, pas se poser de questions. Allez.
[McFly] Ah j'peux pas, j'peux pas !
[Carlito] Putain c'est très dur mec
[McFly] J'peux pas le faire !
[Carlito] Comment tu fais ?
Ehh énergie suprême. Ta gueule !
Appuie sur start frère !
[SQUEEZIE] *rire* J'ai peur
*cris*
*rires*
[Carlito] J'allais juste appuyer là !
[SQUEEZIE] écoutez moi bien
c'est l'objet le plus terrifiant
que j'ai vu d'ma vie
Eh les les gars on finit pas tant qu'on n'a pas fait.
[Carlito] Allez vas-y appuie là frère !!
[SQUEEZIE] Ah c'est génial !
[McFly] Oh c'est une roue
*musique*
*cris*
[Carlito] Ah put**n !!
*rires*
*bruit de verre cassé*
[McFly] J'me suis coupé !
J'viens d'me couper...
Regarde ce moment...
Je suis tomb* y a un verre qui...
[Carlito] Attends attends viens... Déjà : je m'suis pris la décharge
...et vous êtes quand même tous tombés *rires*
[Carlito] Et après... on entend bien...
[McFly] Le verre qui se casse...
...et je me JETTE dessus   !
[Carlito] Regardez ça...
Regardez Mc* nan mais c'est fou
[McFly] Regardez regardez bien quand même parce que là c'est...
[SQUEEZIE] Ouaah mec tu saignes vraiment là
[McFly] Regarde, téma !
[SQUEEZIE]  Et un vrai cadeau un vrai cadeau pour la fin...
*cris de Carlito*
[McFly] Ah pour moi ! Pour moi !
[Carlito] Il a eu que des cadeaux de m*rde depuis le début
[SQUEEZIE] Tiens, j'te laisse l'ouvrir, face à la caméra
[McFly] Aah, quel bonheur !
[SQUEEZIE] Ah qu'est-ce que c'est qu'est-ce que c'est ?
[McFly] Oh...
[McFly] C'EST TOM CRUISE !!
*rires*
[Carlito] C'est la meilleure fin !
[SQUEEZIE] Au revoiir !
[McFly] Merci à tous !
[McFly] Abonnez-vous !
<3